Finland is now officially a member of
the world's largest military Alliance
sis is historic day
the news member of our alliance the
Nordic Nation completed one of the
fastest secession processes in NATO's
history Finland applied to join in
response to Russia's invasion of Ukraine
in February 2022 in the process Finland
ended its decades-old policy of military
non-alignment it will change Russia's
posture towards Europe and nato in
general in the future here's what the
historic expansion means for the
alliance and Security in Europe
first of all Finland adds more than 800
miles to NATO's border with Russia
it also extends the area in which NATO
can conduct its operations the territory
spans about a thousand miles from the
Baltic Sea to the Arctic Finland joining
NATO also means that the NATO alliance
comes closer to the cola Peninsula which
has great strategic importance for
Russia it's where many of its nuclear
capabilities are based and Finland
doesn't come empty-handed as it's one of
Europe's best defended and best armed
countries
Finland has maintained a posture against
Russia where it was ready for conflict
it can mobilize over 800 000 troops and
it's also continued to modernize its
military in the past decade it's
received the surface air missiles rocket
systems and it's even received the f-35s
from the U.S the kremlin's decision to
invade Ukraine radically changed Finnish
public opinion on the country's
non-aligned defense Doctrine in May 2022
support for NATO membership lapsed to 76
percent a fundamental shift from 30 in
January that year just before the
invasion and for Russian President
Vladimir Putin finland's secession is a
major strategic setback there is
definitely a sort of a paradox in this
in these developments given that we know
that Vladimir Putin wants to divide NATO
and the Western Alliance but what he's
actually facing now is a more united
Western Front than ever President Putin
wanted to slam NATO's door shut
today we show the world that he failed
Russia said NATO's enlargement is a
threat to his security and national
interests foreign
's membership of NATO came after months
of diplomatic disputes with turkey
Finland applied to join the alliance at
the same time as Sweden but turkey
alleged the two northern European
countries had connections to Kurdish
militant groups fighting the Turkish
States eventually Ankara ratified
finland's membership but Sweden is still
waiting to join the alliance which needs
the approval of all existing members to
accept any new entrance Sweden
definitely hopes to be a member of NATO
by the end of the year our persistent
efforts for a rapid Swedish membership
will continue
foreign thank you